thank you very much indeed you want to
sign
[Music]
yes there you go
thanks thank you much
cheers see you
l
f
f let's have a look so room
one great good room good condition
happy and then we've got the community
area which is
here which again nice it looks like this
is like a brand new reefer
fantastic
kitchen
nice great water's turned off but the
kitchen seems absolutely perfectly
adequate with a little bit of um a
little bit of TLC that could look
fantastic and let's have a look at the
room so so far we've got one bedroom
downstairs and if we've got three
bedrooms up
here then we're laughing let's say
so so bedroom two is here which again is
great nice double glazing the uh yeah
good Windows
cracking
bathroom
is perfectly
no problems might need a little bit of a
um a little bit of TLC again but mro's
fine
three this is very big get some new
carpets and we'll be we'll be aware with
this walking wro as well brilant and
finally bedroom
for wonderful to be honest I totally
forgot what this place look like cuz
it's been a couple of months since I've
seen it but uh really happy with that
four double bedrooms prime location
right in Mor Hampton Center we'll get
easily ,400 rent and the total cost for
the house 85 Grand I'm happy with
that
hello great thanks thank you thank you
oh sign for other yeah that's
great there you go see you later
bye fantastic so we're just in Warsaw
Center uh great crime location you've
got the Mana hospital really close this
is the
house and we got a free uh pool table as
well
busy road not good if you're wanting to
live in it yourself but for HMO
[Applause]
brilliant okay so here we are this is
the uh this is the front
room now that door actually won't be
used cuz this will be somebody's uh
bedroom and they'll go through the side
but we won't do that now because we've
already jum
through Comm area great it's a bit dark
in here but
uh there we go kitchen
fantastic
kitchen looks pretty good
awesome bathroom not a lot to say really
just yeah not too bad might need a
little bit of touching
up okay let's head upstairs shall
we so downstairs we've got a cun area
we've got a bedroom and then upstairs
let's see what we've
got so bedroom number two
fantastic and then we've got bedroom
number
three over here back of the house quite
stuff and then finally bedroom number
four
bedroom 4 is um I completely forgot what
this was like we've actually got another
little bit up here as well so let's
let's take a
look so I'm sure we can make use of this
area somehow as well i' love to have a
think
on pretty happy with that four double
bedrooms Cally even five prime location
in wara it's going to rent out like
drain for around about ,400 a month and
how the the cost of this house £80,000
pretty happy with that house number two
in just one day great
[Applause]
stuff